donc on va s'arranger pour ça prenne pas
trop de place ils agents municipaux de
mâcon chargée d'installer les panneaux
électoraux n'avaient jamais vu ça on va
regarder ce que ça donne et on sait que
ça fait quand même 33 panneaux sa dette
passe un peu plus que d'habitude
en tout 300 voix panneaux doivent être
installés d'ici demain
un record selon ce responsable ça
complique la tâche par rapport au mètre
linéaire à ce que fauqué panneaux sur
consécutifs et du coup dans le travail
ça nous fait une charge de 50 %
supplémentaires de travail dans le temps
la même durée de temps la municipalité
de mac ont été prises de court malgré
l'installation de fixation permanente
aux abords de la mairie des écoles le
nombre d'emplacements a dû être divisé
par deux faute de matériel suffisant les
élections européennes de mai prochain
constitue un record avec trente-trois
listes aux retenues contre 23 en 2014 et
seulement 19 listes lors du scrutin
organisé en 2009 on se demandera mettre
tous les panneaux électoraux ain azel
commune de 1100 amène 900 électeurs les
impératifs législatifs pèse sur le
budget
la loi impose deux affiches maximum part
pas d'eau malheureusement les formats
d'affichage sans également défini par la
loi donc de toutes les manières nous
n'avons pas d'autre solution que
d'acheter des panneaux pour la
préfecture de saône-et-loire aucune
dérogation ne sera accordé d'ici
l'ouverture officielle de la campagne
prévue le lundi 13 mai d'ici là les
mairies devons trouver des solutions
pour éviter un rappel à la loi